Robin.
Nice to meet you too, Natalie.
Where are you located at?
I'm in New Jersey.
Okay, I'm good. All right. Yeah, so you're not too far from our corporate location. I live in Dallas, but yeah, I go over there a couple times a year.
Yeah.
Right.
Is Jason will be joining us today, Robin?
I don't think so. He hasn't been around too much this week. I can check in with him if you'd like, but he wasn't on our morning huddle, so I suspect he's not joining.
Okay.
The.
Okay, we can get started. We can just check with him if he can join. In the meantime, we can get started. If that looks good.
Yeah, let's go ahead.
Okay.
Great.
Let me share my screen.
Okay.
Okay, I think it's visible.
Okay, quick forward. So this is going to be the quarterly business review for us from Feb to April as we started the agreement in Feb. Let's move forward to the agenda. So we will be going through the check-in and
highlights and action as well as the performance analyst and a couple of other slides.
Okay, so let's start with the how the things are going it right now. Robin with Satyam, if you'd like to share anything related to, you know, related to Satyam.
Yeah, I mean, things are going good. It's really similar to the other check-in calls that we've had, right? He's enthusiastic and he does good work for us. He works more closely with Jason, right, on all the automation work that he does. So I can't give like very specific, you know, technical or operational feedback, but I know that
He's always, you know, like I said, enthusiastic. He seems bright and, you know, any challenges that we've given him or the assignments that Jason has given him, he's attacked and tackled quickly and he's had some good solutions. So, so far, so good. We've been very happy with him.
Great, great. That's a good feedback for us. Moving forward on the highlights. So we covered up related to onboarding, offboarding process, and that's giving us more time usage or time save up to 30 minutes per users.
We have successfully deployed toolkit portal for production and enable for technicians to work on the L1 issues. And we have also developed about the smart asset billing audit for the service as well as incident requests which are raised
during the reports for the asset. We are using right now AI analyst and it's automatically getting out notifications to the stakeholders. Then we covered about, you know, the review for the...
current roost, whatever we have right now, whatever the existing, you know, workflows were there, we are, I think we are still covering it out, but that's in progress. And we also work on the HIPAA compliance chatbot that's currently in the testing phase.
Then we worked on AI power voice agent to design out how we can handle the after hours calls. So that's also in progress right now.
So, these are the, you know, highlights which we go through for this, uh, you know, last three months.
Yeah, that sounds like the projects he's been working on. Now, just to be clear, a lot of those still need work, right? And aren't ready for production yet, but yes, that's what's been keeping him busy, absolutely.
Yeah, yes, yes.
Yeah.
Next is the performance analyst. So right now this is the utilization trend for last three months. So in Feb we started and for a monthly we can say about it's near about 180 and then 170 hours per month. And for April till current we are near about 200.
Ours utilized for Septim as we go through the utilization.
Next, we have automation and performance related, so, so we were focused on towards the development of, you know, internal projects and goal will be on the long-term automation and ongoing.
You know, AI voice agent, it's still in process to operate in after hours, implementing the backend and platform strategies to stable the, you know, further automation readiness. Currently, we are focusing on enabling more automation and compatibility or capability.
for AI integration.
and establishing the, you know, or managing the staging and production environment to improve the testing and releasing of the managed process. So these are the right now, you know, if we talk about automation, which we are working at right now, I know those things are in progress, as you mentioned.
And if you are in progress and we are working on the feedback accordingly, what we are getting up from the team.
Yeah.
Yeah, so way forward will be more focused on the voice agent part to handling the L1, you know, and also that will include the troubleshooting part. So I think the voice agent is already there. And the next step is to get that, if we can add up the basic troubleshooting.
with the, you know, with the particularly whenever we get the ticket. Then to reduce the efforts and improve the efficiency, that will be the part of every project over here. And developing the AI chatbot to streamline the knowledge base as well as the operation access.
Further, we'll be walking through the AI workflows to streamline the ticket handling and ongoing improvement to development stage and make those more stable while we are going through the process.
Anything where you would like to add any project which you know that's not added up or any questions related to any project?
No, I mean, what you said there at the bottom about ongoing improvements, development, staging environments to secure and stable releases, I mean, that's really key is like, you know, what we've, like, it's very easy for new automations to be, you know, it's like, like, sort of like toys in the sandbox, you know, and like they work sometimes and they don't work other times or like they're kind of
Cool, but they don't provide measurable efficiency gains, so, like, that's where we're really focused is like making sure that Satyam's work and the products that he comes up with are stable and work every time and are, you know, consistently improving our, you know, productivity of our of our technicians, right? So...
Mhm.
Yep.
We still have yet to turn some of the projects that you talked about into like stable production ready tools. That's what I want to see next, right? To make sure that like the onboarding workflow works every time without fail. We've had a lot of bugs and challenges with it, but Sachin has been very responsive to fixing those bugs and working through everything.
Yes.
Mhm.
Yeah, I do agree on that part, but you know, it, you know, we have to be like a testing phase and then, you know, review it out with the team and then we go it live with the production, so I think that mostly are on the testing phase right now to see it out with the, you know, the, you know, with the team members.
Right.
to review it and if they have anything where we need to add or remove or any efficiency needs to be added up. So accordingly, we are working on that part. And I do agree that accordingly, then it will be settled up. But I think on that pace, we are working it out. It will be settled out in a couple of months.
To be, you know, you know, if they are mostly on the production and stable release.
Right, yeah, I know. I mean, I see good progress, so I, I think that's, I mean, I think that's true.
Okay.
Kour.
Yeah.
Great.
Next, moving forward with the AI by design.
I think Rick or Natalie, would you like to share more on that?
Yep, I think we are already working with the
On this, I think we are already aligned, Satyam, but other than that, anything you see, because I know if there is any project, you know, team has Robin or Jason, they would be asking Satyam to help with those, you know, creating and building those, but other than that.
Yeah.
Robin, if you see there is something that you guys are working and that's your priority and you want to accelerate that thing, then definitely share with us and we can share how we can help you there.
Okay, yeah. No, I mean, like you said, that's sort of like our goal is to have somebody on staff full time to handle these things. But if we do find that we needed extra support or accelerated development, we will definitely reach out. And we're intending to attend the
I forgot the name of the conference, but you guys have put on. Yes, exactly right. So we were signed up, I think last for the last show and then there was an emergency and unfortunately we couldn't make it. But I know that Jason is still very interested in attending one of the next times that it comes around our local area. So
Build it.
Perfect. Yeah, we actually, I have a VOGO code, so I'll get that over to him as well. So hopefully you both can join since it's not too far from you. But we'll have the AI accelerator is going to be that last day. So we'll have the whole growth, revenue, everything new that's in the AI market. It will be a nice workshop.
Right.
on that last day and then we'll have a nice party at the New York Stock Exchange and it's going to be great cast the theme so it's going to be good.
Cool. Sounds good.
Okay, that's good. Let me share my screen again.
So...
Next part is related to the team GPS, how we are working at.
So this may actually, what we're doing with Team GPS, Robin, I'm sure you've heard of this in the past, but this is actually going to be our Agenic platform. So right now we're moving, we have a product called the Digital Dispatcher, and we're moving that into this platform right now. So basically our goal is that we're creating, we have about 25 use cases.
And our goal is for our customers to be able to just log into the portal. The agent platform is just going to be another extension where you can actually just go in there and purchase it. And then you get connected with the team. We already have the foundation, and then we just have to customize it to your environment there.
Yeah, so I, I know you.
So in addition to all of this, yeah.
You guys had mentioned Team GPS on a couple of these calls. I'm still not like totally clear on what it is. Like, is it like a reporting and like BI replacement? Like...
Yeah, it's a little bit of everything. I wouldn't say it's going to take away all of the Power BI reporting, but if you get the full MSP bots, you can have it kind of similar set up. But what it is, is it will connect to your PSA, it will pull scorecards, it will pull metrics.
Kour.
OK.
It does do all of those things, but it's more like one-on-one manager to person. So it's going to be more individualized in Team GPS. So another thing that it does is it does employee engagement. So there's basically just different modules. So the first module, CSAT, ESAT, so you can get employee, customer satisfaction, all of that's going to be there.
Pre.
And then you have the rewards and recognition. So that's where we shout out each other. ITBD gives us 100 points. So maybe, you know, Jack, you did a pretty good job today. So maybe after this call, I'll send you 10 Team GPS points and say, hey, thanks for doing a great job on the QBR today. So we have those types of things. And then that's all trackable, right? So then as a manager, when you're meeting with your employees, you can see like, oh, actually.
Like, I'm giving this person 100 points, they're not engaging with anybody. So it's just like one of those like different, like it's for culture, but then also it's manager insight as well into some different aspects. And then obviously scorecards all integrated into their group meetings, one-on-one meetings were EOS. So we pretty much designed the group meetings just to.
Mm.
be with our EOS framework, and that's how we're running it there too. So I can give you a full demo if you guys are interested. I know you've been partners for a while, so I figured at some point you may have had a demo, but I can definitely get you into one too.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm open to that, just not right now. Maybe check in with me about it in like a month or two. I mean, we, like a lot of the things you said, like we do use MSP bots and I'm not super happy with it. We also run EOS internally and we run our L10 meetings and things through a different tool that we do like. We use Stready for.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For, you know, stuff, and we we like strategy A lot, so, like, I, it's interesting, you know, it seems like it could cover a lot of bases for us, but yeah, I'm just not sure, so I'm not quite ready yet, but but like I said, maybe in a few months.
Yeah, exactly. It is. It's a little bit of a lift. I don't want to say the onboarding is tough because we kind of hold your hand across the whole process. And then any tool that you're currently using, we can just migrate that data right into this tool as well. So there's no issues as far as like kind of starting with the tool, but that's the goal, right? It's going to take every single tool that you're using right now and then just bring it in into one.
It's also a little HR as well where you can do your performance reviews and everything through that too.
Okay, interesting.
Yep, so a couple months or maybe at Build It too. We definitely have a demo station at Build It and it's going to be just because we're moving AI into this platform, there's going to be a lot at Build It that has to do with Team GPS and AI.
Yeah, sounds good. I'll look out for it.
Pre.
Let me move forward.
So I think this is the conference which is coming up for August. I think this is along with the build ITBD.
Yep.
Yep, it's the same.
Um...
So I think Robin, you're also joining, right, with Jason?
I expect to, yes. Let me look at the dates. Part of the problem is Jason never gave me any warning on these dates, right? And he would tell me like the week before that we have two days at a conference coming up and that didn't work. So we've got August 3rd to 5th.
Pre.
Yeah, I'm going to put that on my calendar now to make sure that at least my time is blocked off. It was two days previously. Is this one different or like is this different from the AI accelerator stuff that we were doing?
It is, yeah, yeah. So this is going to be the full conference. So the AI accelerator now is going to be the last day. So the 5th is going to be the kind of last day of the accelerator. We'll do a workshop there. And then the other ones are just going to be the different breakout sessions. We can send you to, we have the full agenda, so we can send you the agenda.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I've shared quick details here. You also have Great Gatsby Party, Natalie, on 5th. So, yes, so I've shared quick details, Robin, on the chat app. Yeah.
As well.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So what are you saying? You'll want to stay for the last day for sure.
Right, do I do I need to dress up like what Great Gatsby like that?
Yeah.
Yeah, it is. So it is like you'll wear a tuxedo or you know, whatever, whatever those whipper snappers were back then.
A.
Oh, very good.
Eh.
All right, yeah, let me take a look at that info and talk to Jason and kind of figure out what our plan is there, but thank you for sending the information.
If...
All right.
Hey.
Great, other than these are the other services.
Mhm.
Right now, NOC and the team GPS we have already talked about and build ITBD we have talked about.
Uh, Rick, you would like to share it related to NOC and MD?
I think dedicated, we have already set them aligned, but on NOC side, I'm not sure, Robin, you got chance, but we also have our shared NOC services, where if you see any, anything like 100 server, whatever support you need, we have our team 24-7 available. Any alerts coming for those server, network, or workstation, we are responsible taking care of that.
Okay.
Nope.
You just not get team, you get the technical lead plus service delivery manager line and the account manager there. So that's it, that's one of the service. And it just NOC, there are Helpdesk, SOC, and everything is covered there. So any requirement you have in future, just keep us posted.
Yes.
Okay, yeah, I mean, that's something that I may be interested in looking more closely at in the future as we sort of, we're sort of at a transitional point where, you know, like we're sort of like close to being ready to take the next step in scaling a little bit larger than we are now, but we're like, you know, we're waiting on new business, you know, but
Uh-huh.
Like I don't just want to continue hiring service desk techs and TAMs, right? Like I want to start thinking about, you know, maybe an outsource NOC or an outsource SOC or some subject matter experts and specialists, right? So again, not ready right now, but potentially in the future for sure.
Yep.
Well, thank you, thank you for the transparency that helps.
OK.
Okay, but.
Great. Next is a recap. So I will be adding up the tools from this meeting. And that's all from my side.
Any questions?
Right.
No, I'm good. I appreciate everybody's time. Like I've said before, you know, you guys do a great job from the, so not just, you know, Satyaveer and Kelly and Nayan, right, who work with our team, but also all you guys and the meeting cadence and the structure around everything is very much appreciated, very professional, very
you know, just a pleasure to work with. So thank you very much for everything that you do.
Sameer, Robin, Sameer.
That, that's great, that's great.
That's nice. Thanks, Robin. I just got here, so I'm not going to take it, but good job, Jack, Rick. Andy, you get to come into the loop now, too. Yeah, actually, you guys should be there.
And.
from last 1 1/2 month on a daily basis.
Well, Robin, yeah, have you heard about me? Actually, is Jason like grumbling my name around the office or anything?
Yeah.
I, I, I have not. Are you guys, are you guys hitting it off already? Yeah, Jason could be...
No, Rick set me up with his hardware deal. We don't do that in India. And it's like, we ran into all these compliance stuff. We had to change the way that we're doing it. And then Jason's telling me about like the, I'm like, I don't even know, maybe you know, but I don't know, so it's fine.
The.
Ahh.
Yeah.
Oh.
But.
I do, I have heard about the assistance getting some hardware, right? And thank you for that. I haven't been involved in it personally, but I've heard about it and I know that you guys have helped us out dramatically with that. So we really appreciate it.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you, Robin. Thank you, Robin. No, we're trying to, we didn't miss the deadline, but I think we are finally moving, so that's good news.
Yeah, no, that's great. Thank you.
All right, well, yep, great to chat with you. Hopefully I'll get to see you in August at Build It or maybe sometime along the way too, but thank you.
Yeah, sounds good. Thanks everybody. Have a good day. Thank you, Arvin. Bye-bye.
Okay, great.
Thank you, everyone. Take care. Bye.
Thank you. Good day. Bye.
Right.